hi I'm Ted baliker when it comes to
health care who gets treated better man
or man's best friend health care for
pets is definitely much better than
health care for humans if you could
treat humans the same way you treat dogs
and cats it could be a it would be kind
of a sweet thing you know these people
take their pets to dr. Jeff Warburg who
runs Centuri veterinary grouped in Los
Angeles they of course it's hard to make
an apples-to-apples comparison when
you're comparing four-legged patients
and people and there are countless ways
in which human healthcare is better but
pet owners told us there are some ways
where it would be a step up to be
treated like a dog ever been greeted
this warmly at your doctor's office sure
you could probably do without the smooch
on the nose but do you enjoyed this kind
of convenience my clients can get a hold
of me 24/7 and I still give out my
cellphone I had to go to the vet late
and they were about to close and I
called in and they stayed open dog
owners kept telling us how convenient
pet care is a pet health care is much
easier oh it is easy to get into a pet
hospital any time day or night
much easier for my dog than me I think
one of the things that human health care
can learn from veterinary medicine is
the client service side of things the
relationship side of things dr. Peter
Weinstein is executive director of the
Southern California Veterinary Medical
Association
he says various factors explain why
animal care is so client focused this is
high five because of the one Lightfoot
and she gives high fives one reason that
people love what they do
another reason competition there are a
large number of veterinary hospitals
many of them very closely located with
one another so you have to do something
in your practice that will differentiate
you there are hundreds of competitors
within a ten-mile radius of dr. Weber's
office and it would be easy for even
more to pop up well at least easy
compared to opening a human hospital the
requirements for a hospital have to be
astronomical but less red tape makes it
easier to open an animal hospital says
dr. Weinstein who used to run his own
clinic complete with x-ray facilities
and operating rooms
I believe it was 12 weeks from the time
we signed the lease to the time I saw my
first client try to do that in human
healthcare it would take at least 20
times as long to open a comparable human
hospital according to a California
Hospital Association estimate it can
take even longer in states like North
Carolina if you're an animal if you're a
dog or a cat there are eight animal
hospitals within close driving distance
of right where are we speaking right now
there's no hospital for people
something's wrong with that
this spot was supposed to be home to a
new hospital that would serve the
growing community of Holly Springs North
Carolina but state law stopped the
project anywhere in North Carolina it's
complicated state regulators have to
approve projects through a certificate
of need process under certificate of
need or con law if you want to build a
hospital you have to convince state
regulators that the hospital is needed
President Nixon signed the policy into
law because he thought the US had too
many hospitals he thought decreasing the
number of hospitals with lower
healthcare costs but things didn't work
out as planned so basically you ended up
with competitors a would be competitors
being kept out of the market so prices
started going up reason magazines ron
bailey writes about health care policy
he notes that con laws allow existing
hospitals to hold up plans for new
hospitals the existing hospitals go in
front of these government agencies and
say we do not need a new hospital we
don't need any competitors over there
we're taking fine care of the community
here this guy represents existing
hospitals in North Carolina think he
wants a new competitor we don't think
it's in the best interest of the
citizens of North Carolina and so what
you ended up with is a government
regulation that was designed to lower
the cost of health care actually
increasing the cost of healthcare
increasing cost and decreasing
competition consider hospitals that
focus on things like women's medicine or
heart disease states with con laws have
far fewer specialty hospitals compared
to states without such laws even though
both groups have roughly the same
population today 14 states have gotten
rid of their Kahn laws but 36 states
still have them and even when a new
hospital gets the green light from
regulators the fight is far from over
United Regional Medical Center has the
green light from the state to build a
brand new hospital but there's a lawsuit
to stop it guess who's been trying to
stop a new hospital from opening in
Manchester Tennessee to existing
hospitals they fought every step of the
plan for almost two years now frustrated
residents are protesting this 90 year
old lady has begun a petition drive for
a new hospital people resorting to
petitions and protests just because
existing hospitals are afraid of a
little competition there are no special
laws that lets Starbucks prevent other
coffee shops from opening for vanilla
one restaurant to keep other restaurants
away I would be very upset if we took
some of that entrepreneurial spirit out
of the veterinary profession dr.
Weinstein is glad vets don't have to
deal with regulations like con laws it's
great that veterinarians can be
entrepreneurs it allows veterans to be
small business people it allows veterans
to focus on service and care these are
the people who decide how many animal
hospitals there should be in veterinary
medicine we could have two practices
right next to one another and then it's
the consumer deciding to whom they want
to go if that way it's good enough for
these guys maybe it's good enough for us
too for reason TV I'm Ted bellacor
you